so wu-tang is one of the greatest
musical artistic philosophical groups
ever
let's look hundreds of years from now
when humans are robots or aliens or
whatever that's left here they look back
what do you hope they remember about
wu-tang what do you hope the legacy is
well
well even if it's thousands years i hope
we don't get rid of the humans
but you know look whatever happens going
to happen but
i think that uh my philosophy on it is
that
we're gonna
continue to advance
and continue to advance things around us
but i don't see us becoming extinct well
i mean
the reason i bring up sort of wu-tang in
that context and
this is a special moment in human
history it's like a hundred years and
we've created all of this music just if
you think of all the richness of music
that's been created over 100 years it's
like it's not obvious to me that that's
not going to stop right like there's a
flourishing here
so it's it's funny because that i could
see where the
the book of human history is written
there's a chapter on this period of time
right and one of the things we did well
is like all the technological innovation
with like
with rockets and with the internet but
then there's also the musical innovation
and film innovation right just so much
art that's being created and wu-tang is
a huge part of that
so i just wonder what like if there's a
few sentences written about wu-tang
[Laughter]
it just uh
makes me wonder how they remember i
would hope that people will
no matter how you know how many years
are inspired by us
but i will say if i could just use
wu-tang
as itself
so
we we first started off the witty
unpredictable
talent
and natural game right natural gaming
and natural wordplay
and then we went to
the wisdom
of the universe
the truth
of allah
for a nation of god
wisdom universal truth or law nation god
it's just like
so this is go back to a nation of god
let's just take the last two letters
a nation of wisdom strength and beauty
right you know and i'ma go a little
political here but not going political
as we'll say we're the greatest country
in the world
what makes us the greatest
that's to be a question we act is it our
wisdom
is it our strength
is it our beauty now let's say
off the easiest answer you know it's our
strength
we got the nukes
nobody can really you know between
america and russia they said we're just
you know they that's the argument who
could beat them
but where's the wisdom
then they gonna argue well we got the
technology
right but then where's the beauty when
there's so much suffering in the people
so it's not complete the hope is that
the wisdom is in the founding documents
and the imperfect
but wise founding documents of the
celebrated freedom that celebrated
all the ideas sort of having a lot of
nukes having a lot of airplanes and
tanks that's not
that's not uh
that's not important and the hope is
whatever we're doing here
with this quote greatest country on
earth that we preserve the ideas and
help them flourish exactly
well that's what i mean so if we could
get so if you go back to the wu-tang i'm
saying
that's what we're striving for
we're striving for that you know what
man we started unpredictable and just
like yeah just
yeah but like got deep pretty quick
you